[Music]
thanks for including West's neighborhood
house in this discussion West
neighborhood house formerly known as
Saint Christopher house is a
multi-service neighborhood center proud
member of Toronto neighborhood centers
and the Canadian Association of
neighborhood services and even the
International Federation of settlements
and we are our mission is to enable
people to gain greater control over
their lives and over their communities
and more recently our mission statement
still stands but Robin's been helping us
with our theory of change so we're also
committing to a shorter version which is
personal change and social change work
together I'd like to start with just a
bit of an overview but mostly
disclaimers I'm not going to be using
lots of case studies but I did want to
make sure folks knew that any of my
negative references today aren't
referring to the wonderful partnership
we had that were probably most
well-known for with David Hill chance
key and the team at the city center on
neighborhood change and that resulted in
the three cities report that's been on
the globe and star from pages many times
so that was a wonderful community
academic partnership and so we learned
many lessons out of that but we've also
had other experiences and have witnessed
other experiences that have been less
than great between academics and
community working together so my effort
today is to try to improve the impact of
our work together we both I think
academics and community care about the
communities we're looking at and so
we're we we have a good starting point
already I think there's a perceived
problem that we're not seeing to be very
credible and I think there's some
notable exceptions but many of the
audience's that we think are important
maybe don't think we're very credible
and I feel like we're challenged a lot
about our credit
West neighbor house is not a research
shop we're more like as Excel referred
to we work with academics we work with
researchers on project specific pieces
but we are very committed to public
policy and that's that's what's driving
our work is public policy change
so because we get challenged about
credibility we feel we need to be very
critical and self-critical we absolutely
have a role in the problem while
appreciating that there are good reasons
why we're credibility falls down
sometimes and again I really do want to
emphasize we were very fortunate to be
working with a wonderful team at the
city's center and learn some good things
there so I think we've taught Kim's
talked about it excels talked about it
there is an assumption that because
academics want to work with community
and community wants to work with
academics that we have an interest in
changing public policy I was trying to
think of examples of where that might
not be true and I'm sure there might be
some but generally I think we're largely
trying to do this work to influence the
conditions for less advantaged people
and that would lead you to I think
improving public policy pretty quickly
so what do academics contribute to
credibility in terms of public policy
development
one is the rigorous methodologies and I
think Excel we might have some room here
for some debate about the use of gray
evidence or gray research and rigor but
it is a problem in our credibility when
we do use grey research the greater the
rigor is often seem to be lacking in
community and academic partnerships
there's my colleague Diane from Wood
green I think is one of the most vocal
critics and I completely share her
concern about just because it's in the
community doesn't mean that it needs to
be less than fully rigorous so rigor is
really important academics have an
advantage on us in the community because
we're seen to sometimes be feathering
our own nest as community organizations
talking about the need of the community
over and over again
academics don't have that there are jobs
secure and so that sense of some
objectivity and distance is a helpful
thing in terms of credibility and
another big big pieces especially when
you don't have researchers on staff is
academics are up to date in knowledge
however there is a problem around silos
so come to that in a minute as a problem
area what community organizations do in
terms of contributing to credibility is
I think we bring a lot of relevancy to
the table I think we can help identify
issues that are meaningful to the
community and that's not only helpful
for the community but it's helpful to
engage the political representatives
very early on in something if it's
meaningful to the community you can bet
it's meaningful to a political
representative so one of the challenges
we sometimes get is who cares who cares
about this work well being relevant and
to the community really does help answer
that question appropriate solutions I
think that community organizations are
good often as a screen for what's
appropriate not not to be completely
controlling a community's response to
things but sometimes we can head off
some damage by well-intended
research findings that might be
translated into a public policy that
actually has some negative implications
so just a little bit more of the
cumulative lived experience that we've
seen at the frontline as witnesses can
help make sure that there's
appropriateness and nuance in in using
research accessibility is a third area
and this is a very large part of public
policy development is making sure the
language is clear and accessible civil
servants and politicians are smart
enough but they don't particularly care
for some of the language that academics
use and our community certainly is often
feeling lost and left behind with
academic reports so this is the the
challenge we get is often what the heck
are you talking about so accessible
language is is very very important for
that
now Hilary did something tricky with me
here whatever oh there goes the
credibility problems and I'm trying to
pick on both community organizations and
academics equally but if you feel I'm
being unfair please feel free to jump at
me but academics I've talked with some
academics about some of the reluctance
we see for them to get engaged in public
policy they'll do the research but they
don't really see their roles going
beyond that so I've I've really been
asked asking them about that and it's
very clear especially for younger
academics early in their career there's
no incentives for them to get involved
beyond the publishing of their of their
research they may have the best of
intentions but they actually do need to
move on to the next project and publish
some more so that's a built in
structural problem in academia that I
think is is a problem we do know there's
some incentives and things like the CFR
fellowships and others are a really good
way to round that picture out a bit but
I think we need to see a lot more
incentives built in for for academics to
to be involved in in the result moving
the results of their research into
public policy change I I have a pretty
big rant about ideology in community and
academic research I'm gonna try to keep
that lid down but there's really you
know we've been shot down so many times
when we're meeting with political
representatives or civil servants if
anybody mentions the word neoliberal
agenda now there is a very valid
critique about the neoliberal agenda but
honestly it is not something that the
public really likes to hear about they
think it's code for something else
certainly politicians and civil servants
think that that is a big red flag if
you're starting to use that kind of
language so again I'm not saying there
isn't huge validity in a neoliberal
critique but honestly it is something
that falls very flat when you're trying
to move public policy forward it's
something that falls very flat on
community members usually
and I think we really do need to really
watch our language on that so neoliberal
is my pet peeve word but there are other
words and there's other framing of
research and community issues in
abstract language that that is that is
almost insulting to the intelligence of
people that it could be said actually a
much clearer language and it feels over
fancified the third areas that we
believe many academics aren't talking to
each other and increasingly the world I
think demands that were
multidisciplinary so Kim it sounds that
your team is 30 people it sounded like
across disciplines the other issue that
that we have is we think that there's
not a lot of attention being given to
behavioral insights almost all community
work we assume has something to do with
human behavior and there's so many new
insights in behavioral economics or
social psychology that aren't being well
utilized in some fields so there's the a
lot of us in the community don't know
which faculty to go to to find support
or research that would be helpful so I
think there's a big area around
behavioural insights and again it looks
like CFR is is really on top of that and
I think United Way is also very on top
of that we really do need to be getting
at some of these new fields that can
help explain behavior can suggest ways
that we can get some behavior change
well while not letting go of the
structural issues that obviously still
need to be attended to now to pick on
yeah I was gonna skip over critiquing
the community sector but I think I
better get back to that so community
organisations Excel has talked about
this we really lack the resources and
core skills to produce rigorous research
ourselves with notable exceptions like
access alliance would green social
planning Toronto the United Way there
are a few that that actually do that and
and they are doing it at the cost of
something else because they're not
getting funding for this generally it's
not just the money though force core
staff to do it it's also some
this ability to keep on top of current
research or new areas of of insight and
and that's really demanding and and
that's where I think community
organizations need to be clear about
what we don't know this is sort of being
funny about community workers distrust
but actually more realistically they
loathe quantitative methodologies the
use of control groups that kind of stuff
there is a numeracy issue in the general
public to begin with and so our staff
reflect that there there really is a
huge concern that quantitative methods
will miss nuance however I think that at
the sake of nuance we've we've gone so
far sometimes that that we're missing
the quantitative stuff that is possibly
going to make the case so this is again
this issue of which faculty or which
field of expertise do you use can we get
some quantitative stuff and some
qualitative stuff working together
better it's really important and it's a
huge part of the credibility problem I
think we have and many I could many
community organizations I think believe
that okay the reports been published
academically there we go art you know
now the world will know and it's really
not true many community organizations
think that that it's sufficient to just
have this research being done and that's
what I think we're really concerned
about the drop off that happens after
research is done there isn't a lot
moving on to the public policy
development so how do we make use of our
respective resources and speaking with
some academics about this we had a
really interesting conversation about
some of the steps for making
evidence-based public policy changes so
my suggestion and it's very much open to
debate is identifying the issue and the
research question and the appropriate
researchers maybe as the loop is led by
the community organization clearly needs
academic help especially in identifying
appropriate researchers but I think but
the community organizations are the ones
who really need to drive what is
meaningful for the community to be
searched the research I think is
squarely in the hands of academics if
they can use peers and community members
wisely and appropriately that's all the
better but but this seems to me of an
appropriate lead for researchers
engaging people most effective through
the whole process I think we both have
obligations for that and it means some
adjustments for academics and it means
some adjustments for community
organisations to meaningfully keep the
community engaged as they see fit
through these processes and then from
for on is where I think we we see things
have dropped off and I'm suggesting that
we really need to pay attention now from
four to seven those steps are often
missing in public policy development
coming out of community-based research
or community and academics working
together on a community issue
disseminating the research results and
doing public education the need for
clear language and design the need for
us all to be working with contracting
out if poss if necessary to someone who
can clad a research document so clear
language and design is a skill in and of
itself and a lot of people don't have
that skill in our sector or in academia
it's really well worth contracting that
out and doing it in the form of a
briefing note that can be given over to
civil servants and politicians engaging
the public and champions and and
decision makers I think community
organisations are well-placed to be the
lead on that because we have mass in
terms of community members we have some
heft there that might carry some more
weight but we do need champions and I
would include academics as champions as
well there we need help monitoring
implementation of any public policy
changes and celebrating appropriately
and letting people know when there are
positive changes which we almost never
do and also sorry strategizing when
there's news about setbacks and public
policy development or failures and I
think that's something that none of us
are doing enough of is monitoring public
policy implementation and we both have
an obligation to do that and then
finally evaluating the the outcomes over
some period of time I would
say and suggest that that is an academic
responsibility with community
organizations continuing to do it as
well so bottom line I think that maybe
we could be talking more about a
different way of working together a new
kind of partnership between academics
and community organisations with the
explicit goal of public policy change
not the explicit goal of let's just see
what's going on in the community but
it's it's it's to drive through to the
end of the process to say there should
be some changes and improvements in
public policy I think we all need to
acknowledge we have a shared
responsibility for credibility we need
to be checks and balances on each other
there's a real I think mistake in many
community organizations that academics
are the smart ones
well academics can be very smart
academics have education on their side
but community members there's a
tremendous amount of smarts there too
and I think that there's a reluctance to
challenge academics that's really
ridiculous and we do have to get a
little bit more confident about our own
smarts and and we need to challenge each
other because ultimately we're going to
be challenged somewhere else so we
really do need to make sure we're clear
about our work where it's relevant work
the nuances there and to respond to what
would the critics say so before we go
out with anything let's do a test of
what would other stakeholders with some
vested interest against our vision what
would they say and and and work through
that and then finally I think using just
continuing to commit to each other that
will respect each other's complimentary
rules and work together but also let the
academics do what they do best and let
the community do what they do best all
the while working together and in
cooperation so that's my my presentation
I'd be happy to take any questions or
challenges
I just want to say thank you for what is
a very thoughtful and balanced and also
solutions oriented presentation and
approach I think you've given a lot of
concrete suggestions on both how to
leverage credibility better on both
sides but also some practical and
specific ways that that academics income
you could work more closely together so
let's spend some time now but also later
in the smaller groups you know digging
specifically into some of these
suggestions on you know what would it
take for this paradigm to shift what
would it take to have more wins and more
concrete examples like we're hearing up
today of these successful relationships
and partnerships so let's open it up
any yep please good morning
Thank You Maureen there's questions for
Maureen and for Excel I'm mark Campbell
from the Center for the Arts have in in
your 10 year experience of community
research and from your experience with
Saint Christopher house have there been
winds in in terms of public policy
change that has been celebrated both
with your team and on the academic side
because I know as a metric in
universities social policy change is not
necessarily at the top of the list if it
has nothing to do with tuition fees and
head counts and and you know funding of
students so maybe if either you can
respond to that that would be great
we've done some public policy work
without academics the modernizing Income
Security for working age adults had very
minimal academic presence in it but it
did have some researchers policy
analysts and with there were some winds
out of that the entire child benefit is
one of them the working income tax
benefit is another they're not perfect
solutions and we can't claim all the
credit for them but it certainly we feel
the mobilizing effort that we did with
some of the research so there's a common
database that no one disputed multiple
stakeholders including very very
conservative folks as well as activists
people with lived experience agreed on
it was very powerful politicians in a
way couldn't say no
so that that's concrete but it's not
that doesn't that wasn't really out of a
community University Alliance the
neighborhood change project with David
Hill chance key and and the large
academic team there we haven't seen
obviously the kind of changes we would
like to see certainly the public
attention is on the issue of increased
income inequality and how it plays out
geographically I still don't think
that's a win I don't think we should
give up yet on on that because we
haven't just getting more publicity is
not in in my view a win at all but Excel
do you have other examples we take
credit for a lot of things so I mean
years ago the first research project we
did which was looking at needs and
issues related to immigrants and
refugees in the shelter system and you
might remember Maureen years and years
ago there was and we were we were
actually really strategic about engaging
with the city and there were what there
was at that time a response a funding
response related to making language
interpretation available to shelters
which previously hadn't been putting
settlement workers in shelters and then
there were a couple of others sort of
less sort of service see but more policy
I think there was a change or a revision
of training for shelter workers and I
mean we were you know we did the
research work and then we were we
created all of these working groups with
committee members and staff which led to
all of this but I think that's an
example of sort of a service a focus we
like to think that we were the first
ones to start talking about precarious
employment and now it's on the world's
radar so yeah there has been there we
wouldn't be able to continue this work
if we didn't have some successes but we
could do a better job for sure of
talking about them and building on them
[Music]